Oh another animal hater we're gonna look
at some of your film and we're gonna see
what he said now that many right yes
with no it is I who normally don't like
Kevin Hart at all was so impressed with
his dramatic chops that I am going to
recommend I mean what type of compliment
and insulted the same talk about the
upside you talk about the upside how you
making napkin dance put a little boogie
in it oh look look
the movie is stupid dumb every ticket
lots but but the end brings at home and
a way to that seat might be might be a
good time
only if you're drunk Wow yeah stupid fun
and ridiculous but it might be a good
time yeah maybe you're drunk god
Baywatch no bat-time [ __ ] rampage
really Oh another animal hater another
animal hater whoever you are
oh my god son of a [ __ ]
tolerable so just tolerable that's it
that's all you get is taller it's all I
give which this which this movie was 73
percent certified fresh it's great fun
and nowhere near as annoying as I can't
including Jack Black and Kevin Hart's -
oh my god you guys hi Wow I'm a nerd
destined for heavy rotation on TNT it'd
be to be half watched for a few minutes
at a time by channel surfers at laundry
folders won't ask me any one thing like
a mean there is a - that's right a lot
if you are suffering from bricks it
blues then watching a tiny comic
repeatedly clocking a hulking muscle man
around the chops could be just what the
doctor ordered
[Laughter]
donors will enjoy everyone else everyone
helps to stay home and watch Chappelle's
Show
but stoners will enjoy this movie one we
reference off not so much a story as the
rots up the body workout with explosions
CGI'd behind it
due to the day 2018 Rapinoe skyscraper
yes got any duct tape by the way I can
tell them a lot of these people tuck
their sweaters in that's just a fact
[Music]